c'est une véritable tradition pour la
dixième année consécutive le trophée des
entreprises est organisée ce jeudi en
fin d'après midi sur l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines notre
journaliste michael et demi d'euros et
sur place et il nous présente le concept
de cette compétition sportive qui réunit
une cinquantaine d'entreprises
comme vous pouvez le voir le départ sera
donné dans quelques minutes juste
derrière moi le concept est simple 5 140
compétiteurs classés en trois catégories
hommes femmes et mixtes vont courir par
équipe de trois et comme son nom l
indique la compétition concerne à les
entreprises ces dernières sont
essentiellement issus du territoire
adhésives in or on trouve par exemple
l'entreprise airbus d'elancourt des
teams du technocentre renault de
guyancourt ou encore la poste de saint
quentin en yvelines il ya également une
école qui sera présente avec le collège
einstein de magny les hameaux encore des
mairies comme celle de trappes comme
tous les ans la compétition se déroule à
travers l'île de loisirs petite
particularité cette année les
participants s'élancent du vélodrome
national de 50 en ligne le site qui
accueillera peut-être les jo en 2024 les
compétiteurs devront aussi être en forme
olympique pour disputer la compétition
au programme 1 5 km de course à pied il
y aura également 2,5 km2 avec dix
balises à pointer ce qui ne devrait pas
être une mince affaire pour nos
compétiteurs il faudra aussi être à
l'aise sur l'eau avec une épreuve de
radeaux de 500 m les sportifs
termineront avec un relais de vtt site
de plus d'1 65 km avant de terminer par
un bike and run les meilleurs devraient
terminer la compétition à un peu moins
d'une heure